Film Courage: At what point did the stakes rise for
you with making films where you had
money that was given to you and it
became more serious and then it became
more stressful at times because now
you're responsible for more? How did
you handle this? Brad Sykes, Filmmaker: I think that one of the
movies that that happened for me on was a
movie idea called DEMON'S KISS which was...well it was a big...was the biggest budget
I'd had until that point I'd probably
directed five or six movies to that
point and DEMON'S KISS was a bigger
budget was shot on film.
That's right off the bat that's puts you
in another bracket economically you know
and it was a longer schedule and was
just a bigger film and it was the first
film I was making for this particular
company and I was I think this and also
it was a script that I hit was a concept
I had pitched to the investor which I
should point out that a lot of the films
are made back then especially horror
films and exploitation films and stuff
sometimes someone would just come to you
or they'd come to the producer you're
working with and say we want to make
this movie X movie and are you in or
you're out they already had a title
they're at artwork they'd already done
pre-sales and Milan or something and
they it was your choice whether you want
to be involved in the movie or not
demons kiss was something I pitched I
had the title the concept and I pitched
it and it got the green light so and I
was writing it and directing it so I was
I was very it was very important to me
not only to handle the you know the
production well and and you know come in
on budget and you know that was but to
make a good movie that I'd be happy with
too because I was actually getting more
resources to do it with you know that
was that was one of the films I think
for sure that I was you know and it
wasn't I can't say I had fun making that
movie you know I mean I've made movies
what I all of him say is the movies I've
had the most fun making they didn't turn
out as well or they didn't do as well
some of the ones that have been
nightmares to make they they're like my
most of my most successful films you
know I it's
I don't know why exactly that is
sometimes because I work hard on
everything I direct but it just turns
out that way sometimes demons kiss was a
was a really hard movie to make it
wasn't a huge pit necessarily but it
wasn't you know didn't disappear either
it's kind of somewhere in the middle but
I just remember every day on that
talking about a little different
location every day I had to DPS I had a
DP who was forced on the production who
was more or less trying to take over the
movie I had to take him aside early on
and tell him that that's not going to
happen that's not gonna work and and
after that he was fine but that was
something I had to contend with on the
first day of shooting there was a lot of
nudity in the film it was an erotic
thriller and it was the most of those
type of scenes I've ever ever had to
direct at that point so thankfully the
actors are really cool and professional
and all that but that was kind of a
challenge for me too
and I just you know just the
post-production was also very
challenging let's just say in terms of
the movie I saw it being vs. with the
executive producer saw it as being but
yeah that was probably the first times
I'm her feeling and I just got married
too so it was like it was first movie I
made after I got married and and we've
been prepping it for a long time so you
know you have the more prep you have
sometimes the more psyched out you can
get that's why I don't like to have too
much crap on a film like I've sung but
not too much because after a while you
can start to psych yourself out a bit
that's really interesting the the ones
that didn't turn out the best actually
were the most fun and then vice versa
that's it's weird I mean like for
example I mentioned this movie death
factory that had in blockbuster my first
movie in Blockbuster ok that was a
nightmare to make that movie we're
shooting in a location that didn't have
running water and barely had electricity
there are no bathrooms and it was
interior and it was in the dead of
summer super hot and we were like being
in fans that it wasn't enough it was a
haunted attraction like a closed down
haunted attraction that we were shooting
in that was closed for the summer but
they it was just a
you know was ridiculous and there was a
lot of effects there was a lot of gore
everyone was getting covered in blood
sticky blood and our days would always
go longer and longer and you know it was
one of those shoots where you start off
with normal days and then by like day
five or six years starting in like 5:00
p.m. you know and it was really tough to
make but that ended up being one of my
most well known successful movies I will
say we were making it I had a feeling
about it that it would do well that it
would do well and they would turn out
well actually I don't know how I managed
to do well I knew would turn out well
because I just could see what I was
seeing on screen I could see that you
know in the monitor and on set I could
tell that it was delivering it was a
kind of movie I'd like to see you know
that I would be happy with it if I
rented it
that's like my gauge a lot of times you
know most of the time is I want to see a
film I want to make it from that I'd
like to see that I'd be happy with as a
jaded horror fan you know so yeah does
one start out a jaded horror fan or
already builds after it builds it builds
because because I see I interact a lot
with like fans and stuff and there's
like fans of different generations who
like my so my older movies and stuff and
there's like just starting out and it's
funny because like people who it's fun
to almost to see somebody get excited
about some 80s slasher that you've seen
like 20 times or you've seen 10 times
and you're like yeah whatever what's the
big deal about that but what is a big
deal to them now because they're just
discovering it but you do get yeah once
you see more and more stuff you do get
jaded yeah and then you've made movies
too on top of it you really get you know
it's it's hard to maintain the kind of
enthusiasm and you know the excitement
about new release horror
you know sometimes right you know we all
I'm coming here whatever age I always
say well I'm not going to end up like
that like so dream crusher or whatever
and then I think enough things happen
and you don't mean to do it and I'm not
saying that's how you are I'm just
saying but we all have to like check
ourselves because it's like so easy you
do it jaded about whatever it is I saw a
lot of that too
when I first moved here I saw it from
guys who are in their 40s right when I
was in my early 20s or get into my
mid-20s I saw guys in their 40s who are
super jaded and I thought they had the
best jobs in the world and I'm like what
are you complaining about what's your
problem and you know of course there are
levels to all these things that people
if you don't really know them you don't
know the whole story or but I I mean
just having said that this is a general
statement I think it's very very
important to keep your enthusiasm about
what you're doing and your gratefulness
for what you've been able to accomplish
because you know it's very very hard to
make any movie any movie any type of
movie any budget movie whatever it's
very very difficult and anyone who does
that I mean that's an accomplishment
right there and there's you know if
you've been able to blend lucky enough
to make a few and then then some of
those have actually gone out and have
fans and people that like your stuff and
they appreciate what you've done that
that's you know you should be very
appreciative of that I think I don't
think you should ever lose your
appreciation for that or your love of
the game and it's really hard to lose
your loop it's really easy to lose your
love of the game because this is a very
difficult game to be in it's probably
easier to maintain your love of cinema
than it is the business of cinema you
know but you can't have one without the
other so yeah that's true I know so I
think if you dip your toe back into what
you don't want then you have a new
appreciation for kind of like what you
have a little bit because ya can I think
it's very easy to see the glass half
empty we I think we're as humans are
engineered that way no matter what we're
doing what field ran but I see it
sometimes from other filmmakers that
seem like they're not my peers who have
also some very cool accomplishments but
they always seem to focus on the thing
that they didn't get the store that
their movie didn't get into the festival
they didn't get into the money they
didn't make the this that and I'm
thinking you know you can choose to see
it that way but there's so many other
good things that have happened for your
film that you ought to be happy with and
sometimes that's something that
Josephina I talk about is let's always
be grateful and thrilled for the stuff
that goes right and stuff that works and
the people that approached us about
doing cool things with the movie because
you should be appreciative of that stuff
and there's a lot of people out there
doing it you know the more people now
that when I started making all kinds of
movies so you do have to kind of you
have to train yourself to see it
half-full I think because there's a lot
of negativity but you just don't want to
get and let that be the mean you're like
your go-to reaction you know right and I
like what you said about there's
difference between the love of cinema
and then the love for the business but
sometimes the love of cinema can
reignite it it does it does I mean like
we watch movies you know regularly and
all different types of movies new movies
old things we haven't seen sand those
watch something that we just both love
and like we both love Paul Schrader
films and like when we first met we
first started talking my Paul Schrader
and I thought there was a girl that
knows who Paul Schrader is and was like
and she's in Romania and she loves
horror movies and and you know because
most people like in was in film school
most people were only interested in
Kevin Smith and Tarantino they didn't
care about Bob Fosse shrade or freaking
you know any of these guys so and I was
more interested in that type of stuff so
we'll just watch something that we
really love that we know it's good and
then you discover another layer of it
usually because these are great films
they hold up for you know we're P
viewings and you discover another layer
whether it's the sound or the
photography or a performance or
something so yeah you need to renew your
your love for movies that way I think
for sure yeah and when all else goes
wrong just yes yeah it's absolutely
absolutely remind you why you're doing
this while you're putting yourself
through this and guess what otherwise
why way it's torture that I'm torturing
myself you're why you know well you're
it's something you're aspiring to and
it's also a world that you want to
contribute to and that's what we're you
know that's what we're doing this
because we want to contribute to to film
to the you know not to sound pretentious
but the you know the art of cinema or
the history of film or whatever you want
to call it sort of must love dogs most
love well not even right exactly that
would be yeah prerequisite must be a fan
of Americans
and cat people
you